we find ourselves in a curious situation
in the
current world in some parts of the world
especially in secularized europe
being religious is sometimes seen as
something
rather embarrassing something irrational
religion generally seen as often being
dangerous
or opposed to modern ideals
but at the same time people also love to
call themselves
spiritual the term i am spiritual but
not religious
is a very common term in many of these
contexts the bulk of our skepticism
towards religion is usually aimed
at or towards christianity to the
majority of people
in europe for example christianity is
the religion by which
other religions are measured
christianities even the religion by
which
the very word religion and what it means
is kind of based there's the framework
upon which
we understand what religion is supposed
to be in that sense
christianity often comes to represent
something old and outdated something
irrational silly beliefs in some
man in the sky who watches over us and
by contrast
and by comparison many of the religions
from the east so
we say hinduism or buddhism and these
kinds of religions
are viewed in a very different light in
the
western world in europe this is partly
the result of a very shallow
understanding of the christian tradition
and a romanticizing of the more
exotic religions like the eastern
traditions
many of the theological critiques aim
that christianity like for example the
idea that
they believe in some man in the sky is
often more based on popular culture
than it is on actual christian theology
the intellectual tradition of christian
theology and
mysticism is a broad deep and complex
one
and a lot of it would probably be very
intellectually stimulating to those who
were willing to
actually look a bit deeper rather than
through very shallow
pop culture infused misrepresentations
in fact many of those ideas and
philosophies that are so appealing to
many people in the eastern religions are
usually very much present in the
abrahamic religions including
christianity
in christian mysticism for example we
find many striking similarities with
teachings from
buddhism advaita vedanta sufism
and some forms of taoism and this is why
i want to dedicate this video to one of
the most
fascinating thinkers mystics and
philosophers
in european and christian history
the dominican friar from germany the man
from whom god hid
nothing meister eckhart
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this video is brought to you by our
wonderful patreon community and as
always i'm going to be mentioning some
of the new arrivals to our patreon team
i would like to thank danny van heck
arteris flitz
george asconis i would like to thank
also carl tapps i would like to thank
mats
orman simulation
mo s and marilyn zachla
berger and a special thank you to our
group of saints
wahsev khan greg corbin adam schreibe
muhammad hanan fikri say jafari
and amulatif without all of you this
channel would not be possible so i can't
thank you all enough
thank you thank you thank you so much i
will leave a link to my patreon page
in the description if anyone else wants
to join our little community
eckhart van gaal is one of the most
influential figures in christian
mysticism
one whose radical expressions of oneness
with god in the ground of the soul
garnered accusations of heresy but also
a list of devoted admirers and followers
eckhart was born in germany near the
city of gotha
and around the year 1260. his earliest
years are quite obscure
but we know that he probably entered the
dominican order in early adulthood and
became a friar
in these monastic orders of christianity
the difference between a friar and a
monk is that a monk lives in a
cloistered community that is isolated
from the world
whereas a friar will take all the vows
of celibacy and poverty
while still living within society and
doing things like teaching and preaching
to the masses and indeed the first time
meister eckhart
appears in the historical record is in
1294
when he holds an easter sermon in paris
as a junior professor
only one instance that shows maester
eckhart's very active and distinguished
career as a teacher and preacher in
different convents and in different
universities
as a young dominican he would study
theology and philosophy
perhaps under albert the great in
cologne
he seems to have been strongly
influenced by albert as well as thomas
aquinas
both of whom were his older
contemporaries
the dominican order at this time was
characterized by a strong scholasticism
and thereby a big
emphasis on philosophy as an important
complement to
revelation and theology more broadly
they were especially influenced by the
greek philosopher aristotle and studied
many of his works along with his muslim
and arabic commentators like ivan rust
or averroes
to the dominicans rational philosophy
was an important part
in understanding the bible and its
message properly
something that distinguished them from
the other major order at the time the
franciscans
who were often highly critical of using
aristotelian philosophy
at this time this was in fact a huge
debate in the
larger christian world these two
opposing sides which
are often represented by the dominican
order on the one hand and the franciscan
order on the other
often argued about the music
compatibility
of philosophy and theology or revelation
meister eckhart naturally since he was a
dominican
argued very much in favor of the use of
philosophy and aristotelianism when we
read his works and his
sermons we can clearly see very strong
use and influence from
the aristotelian tradition this is at
the core of meister eckhart's ideas
as a teacher of theology and philosophy
we know that eckhart worked as a
lecturer on the works of peter lombard
in paris
in the 1290s and after this he would
spend his time moving around a lot
between different cities in the region
for
basically the rest of his life being
appointed to different positions of
authority
a large portion of his life was spent in
a convent in the city airfort
which is often considered his home
convent this is
where he spent most of his time he would
preach here to other monks and and
members of the dominican order he would
write many of his commentaries on the
bible and so on in the year 1302 eckhart
returned to paris
being appointed the regent master which
is the highest teaching position in the
entire order
which is a kind of professorship with a
teaching commitment
only a year later and between the years
1303 to 1311
he served as provincial that is the
dominican authority over the entire
province of
saxonia which is eastern and northern
germany
he was very successful here as well
founding a few convents for women and
retaining a very high status within the
dominican order
after this he returned once again to
paris to serve a second term as regent
master
this time for two years before
relocating to stroudsburg
in 1313 and finally to the city of
cologne in either 1323 or 1324
where he spent his last years all of
this to show you that eckhart was no
controversial mystic on the fringes of
society or the church at least for most
of his life
he was a very successful and reputable
man within the dominican order and
also through that in the church
generally
in all his time moving around from
different cities he wrote many
literary works primarily in latin much
of this corpus of his writings
consists of latin works that are mostly
commentaries so philosophical
commentaries on certain books of the
bible
these latin works of prose are
fascinating and interesting enough in
themselves
but it wasn't here that he left his
biggest mark
on history indeed eckhart was a
magnificent
preacher and he preached a lot he
preached in
convents and universities but he also
preached to the general masses around
germany
and in these sermons he used the
vernacular language of
middle high german that is the language
spoken by the
regular people indeed this was a time
when the german language had begun to be
used in a religious way primarily by
some of the
women mystics of the region like the
begins for example now eckhart of course
picks up on this general trend and in
the region and
uses his native language of german to
get very creative linguistically and
create some truly
awe-inspiring imagery and phrases
many of eckhart's sermons survive in
written form
and they make up the bulk of what has
made him so
controversial but also so beloved at the
same time
the use of the vernacular language
allowed eckhart to create a very
emotional and vibrant way of talking
about his mystical ideas about god
the soul and the reunion among many
other things
this is somewhat in contrast to his
scholastic treatises which being tied to
the much more established theological
language of latin
does not come off as creative and as
striking
but these sermons along with some of his
latin treatises as well
did get him into some trouble indeed by
the end of his life he was actually
tried for heresy
by the pope john the 22nd certain
sections from his writings and sermons
were picked out
as being possibly heretical and or
dangerous
and he had to defend himself both in
person and
in in written form in any case this was
of course a long
process there was an investigation
eckhart had to
defend himself and in trials and and so
on
this process was so long in fact that by
before it even ended eckhart had already
died we're not entirely
sure how or when eckhart died but
scholars suggest that he probably died
of natural causes he was pretty old at
this time
and that it may have been on january 28
1328 as the investigation against
eckhart concluded after he died
he was not actually deemed a heretic as
opposed to what many people tend to say
when they talk about this
instead 28 parts or 28
sections from his writings or sermons
were picked out
and deemed as either heretical or as
dangerous which indeed did leave
a kind of a black mark on his reputation
for some time afterwards but this did
not stop him of course from being
immensely popular and as having
many devoted followers and students
and today he is generally accepted as a
great teacher
within the catholic church but now it's
time to get into the meats of the
discussion
what were these ideas that were so
powerful and controversial
what did he say in his sermons and his
written works
now eckhart can be a seriously difficult
thinker and there is often disagreement
on how he should be interpreted
or how some of his ayat core ideas
should be understood
but one of the foremost scholars of
eckhart today
bernard mcginn has argued that if
eckhart's teachings or ideas can be
summarized under one phrase or name
it would be the mysticism of the ground
the ground is in fact one of the central
themes in all of his sermons
and a concept which everything else
revolves around
the original word which eckhart uses is
the german grunt
which is as we have seen translated as
ground but in fact can have a much
broader and more creative use in its
original german
form in the words of megin quote
grunt can first of all be understood as
physical ground
that is the earth grunt can also mean
the bottom or lowest side of a body
surface or structure abstractly grunt is
employed to indicate the origin
cause beginning reason or proof of
something
finally grunt is employed as what is in
most hidden and most proper to a being
that is
its essence in some ways this is quite
different from how the word ground
usually functions in english
and thus the word german word grunt
gives eckhart the opportunity
to play around a lot with terms and
concepts but in any case the way that
eckhart uses the word grunt
is to signify a radical and striking
point about the nature of reality
to the dominican master the ground of
the soul
and the ground of god is one and the
same
ground in fact in a lot of his sermons
and writings he talks about the ground
in an indistinct way so
he's not talking about the divine ground
or the ground of the soul
because when he talks about the ground
there is no distinction between these
two
quotes it is not because either the soul
is grounded in its essential reality
or god in his but because they are both
grounded in the same ground in a fused
identity
that eckhart and his followers found the
language of the ground so rich
in meaning the ground or grunt is a
metaphor that describes the very zenith
or
center of reality or the divine it is
incomprehensible
beyond all being or language or
particularity
it is god but it is also beyond god
what i mean by that is that is beyond
god as we commonly understand
god it is beyond the trinity of the
christian theology or even the
oneness of god itself but it nonetheless
is god in god's absolute and essential
reality
the ground is utterly the silent and
empty abyss which in german
is ab grunt by the way that is the true
essence of the godhead
it is the starting point of reality from
which everything
including divinity emanates and to which
everything eventually flows
back and in the grunt there is no
distinction
the soul and god everything is
absolutely indistinct from each other
they are fundamentally one eckhart
himself puts it in very plain words
quotes
god's ground and the soul's ground is
one ground
and quote here god's ground is my ground
and my ground is god's ground and this
sounds radical of course and to some it
may appear to go against what is
perceived as christian orthodoxy
but eckhart existed that this is an
essential feature of christianity
and the divine word quote now know all
of our perfection and our holiness rests
in this
that a person must penetrate and
transcend everything created in temporal
and all being and go into the ground
that has no
ground we pray our dear lord god that we
may become one
and indwelling as this section suggests
the ultimate goal
is to penetrate back into god to detach
from the world of particularities and
individualism
and return back to our source and
eventually the further we reach even god
himself will
unbecome as court the mystic is not
content to return to the god who acts
but effects a breaking through to the
silent unmoving
godhead as we break through we reach
beyond the god as commonly perceived
beyond the trinity and enter into the
silent empty desert of the ground the
grunt
where god and human achieves indistinct
identity
in the simple one but this indistinction
and oneness is
always there it is not that the mystic
becomes one with god
but realizes it is already essential
oneness
of course many christian mystics and
thinkers prior to eckhart had also
talked about
uniting with god but in most cases this
was referring to a kind of
intimacy with god or as being one with
god in
spirits and not necessarily a complete
identity between the two
but this indeed seems to be what eckhart
is indicating
the closest we find to eckhart's
expressions is
in the uh christian mystic women of the
13th and 14th centuries and especially
in with the begin movement in the
writings of
some of these begins like mech till the
magdeburg or
we find similar expressions of oneness
with god
and especially in the french mystic
marguerite paret
who had been burnt at the stake for
heresy in 1310
so right around the time that eckhart
would hang around in paris as well
it's quite likely thus that eckhart was
familiar with her
masterpiece the mirror of simple souls
which is what got her executed
it would thus be safe to say that
eckhart was influenced on the one hand
of course by some of the great
scholastic philosophers and theologians
like
albert the greats and thomas aquinas but
also
by some of the begins that were
flourishing in the region at the time
both in language and also in ideas but
the concept of ground or grunts and its
identity with both
god and the soul is really only the
starting point of eckhart's very complex
theology and metaphysics he has a lot
more to say on subjects like
well god the soul creation and ethics
among that much more the more scholastic
metaphysics of eckhart's works
expressed in his latin treatises and
commentaries on the bible
paints the picture of a very complex and
often hard to understand theology
eckhart even warns himself that if not
understood
properly many of the things he says will
come off as heretical
there is a lot to go through here so
bear with me
but let's start with that very central
thing to
well most christians which is of course
god
who is god and how does eckhart
understand him
well the first thing that needs to be
understood is that eckhart's theology is
a
heavily negative or apophatic one what
this means is that
he applies the sort of theology where
when all is said and done
nothing can be said or grasped about god
he is utterly beyond any description or
intellectual understanding
and the best response is really just
silence
in this he is heavily influenced by two
of his predecessors
his fellow dominican thomas aquinas and
the jewish philosopher
maimonides indeed to eckhart god
in his absolute ground grunt is even
identified as
nothingness as a total and absolute
absence of anythingness
and an absolute abyss and darkness which
cannot be grasped
but he still has a few things to say
about god and one of the key discussions
here is on the so-called transcendentals
that is attributes or qualities that
apply to god and creatures
which includes things like being in
existence
oneness goodness and truth
in eckhart's thought god is in fact the
only one who possesses these qualities
so god is being an existence god
is goodness god is oneness and none of
these things belong to created things
quote analogouts have nothing of the
form according to which they are
analogically ordered
rooted in positive fashion in themselves
but every created being is analogically
ordered to god in existence
truth and goodness therefore every
created being radically and positively
possesses existence
life and wisdom from god and in god and
not
in itself indeed one of the most
recurring themes in eckhart is that he
identifies the essence of god
with being itself a more precisely
indistinct being meaning he doesn't have
being in the sense that a creature or
anything has a being or existence he is
pure
being or pure existence in itself
and because god is the sole possessor of
this attribute
this means that when it comes to created
things like me and you
and all things in the universe they are
absolutely nothing
in themselves any being or existence
that you or i have
is really god's being and thus identical
to god himself
insofar as it is being and the same can
be said about the other transcendental
qualities like goodness
god again is goodness itself and any
goodness
in creatures is really god's goodness
here it is important to grasp one of the
key features of eckhart's thought
the so-called in quantum principle often
expressed with the term
in so far as so if we return to the
quality of goodness for example
a good person is participating in
eternal goodness and thus god himself
insofar
as he is good the good person is
god insofar as he is good because
goodness
is nothing but god himself and yet in
his entire created reality he is not god
whatsoever he is
that which god isn't he is nothing
but again insofar as he has being he is
nothing other than god
since god is being itself so again we
can look at the world and
creation itself as utter nothingness
it's it has no being has no goodness all
these qualities only belong to god
and creation and the things in the world
are really just
emptiness they're nothing they're
nothingness entirely but in some way at
the same time they share
in these quality or they don't share in
the qualities but it is god's qualities
that are sort of
experienced through this nothingness of
the created things
quote if my life is god's being then
god's existence must
be my existence and god's is-ness is my
is-ness
neither less nor more and this paradox
is something that you'll have to get
used to
it is in fact one of eckhart's favorite
ways of talking about god
since nothing can truly be said about
god the purpose of eckhart's
weird expressions and paradoxes is not
to actually
describe god in any real way but instead
to in
bernard mcginn's words quote frame the
appropriate paradoxes that would serve
to highlight the inherent limitations of
our minds
and to mark off in some way the
boundaries of the unknown territory
where god dwells in one sense and very
importantly
god is absolutely and utterly
transcendent of the world
and creation this is not a pantheism in
the
common sense of that word god is utterly
distinct and different from all created
things because he
is being itself and they are nothingness
but at the same time god is all things
and there is nothing which is not
god god is the existence of all things
in an absolute sense but not in the way
that he sort of dwells
within them or in their created nature
he's not
incarnated in all things and eckhart
talks about this paradox in a very
unique and clever dialectical language
by affirming that it is god's
distinction that is his very
indistinction
it is god's utter difference from
creation that is the same as his other
sameness and imminence
indeed aside from indistinct being or
existence
two of the favorite words of eckhart to
describe god is
unity and oneness unum and intellect
he shows his clear debt to aristotelian
philosophy by essentially conceiving of
god as
pure intellect pure thinking awareness
and knowledge
in some spots he even places this aspect
of god as being above
being itself quote it does not now seem
to me that god understand because he
exists
but rather that he exists because he
understands
but even more important for our current
discussion is the word unity or oneness
or unum
which is applied to god as well to
eckhart god
in his absolute essence is of course one
and consists of a unity
this doesn't deny the doctrine of the
trinity of course as we will clearly see
soon
but that in essence god is oneness to
echo
then to be one means the same as to be
indistinct
quote we must understand that the term
one is the same as
indistinct in other words not to be
distinguished for all distinct things
are
two or more but all indistinct things
are one
think of it this way existence is
distinguished by the fact that it isn't
distinguished at all
everything partakes in existence and
that in itself is what is unique
about existence so existence is distinct
or
unique by the very fact that it is
totally indistinct or the same
and this is true of god since he is
existence
the more he is different the more he is
the same by that very logic
now if you've been watching this channel
for a while i know what you're thinking
this sounds eerily similar to the ideas
expressed by the sufi thinker ibn arabi
and his school of or the unity of being
and indeed the similarities up to this
point are many and
hard to ignore it could be the result of
a common influence from neoplatonism i
think that's probably a huge part of it
but there could also be other factors
involved
in any case it is a very fascinating and
interesting
comparison to make because there are
certainly so many similarities here
but meister record is also very unique
of course being a christian and a
dominican friar
his ideas are very much influenced and
grounded in those traditions as well
indeed as most of you probably know the
main theological idea of mainstream
christianity
is the idea of the trinity that is that
god is
one but that he consists of three
different
persons the father the son and the holy
spirit
so how does eckhart relate his ideas
about the ground that is god
beyond god with the doctrine of the
trinity and how do we get from
this silent desert this silent emptiness
to the creation
of the universe in this discussion
eckhart is likely strongly influenced by
neoplatonism
because the key feature of his
metaphysics is one of divine
outflow and inflow referred to as exetus
or usgank
and reditus or in other words everything
flows from the divine ground and also
flows back
into that same ground and it is with
this flowing or emanation that all
things including the trinity or
god comes to be starting with the
flowing out from god there are two
stages or modes of this outflow
the first of which is referred to as
bulitzio
this is an activity that takes place
within god himself
and is thus prior to any creation this
activity is
sometimes described as an inner boiling
in which the three persons of the
trinity
come to be since this is all happening
in god who is beyond time and space we
should not think of this as
a temporal activity this inner boiling
take place in the eternal now
as eckhart calls it god or the father is
always giving birth to the son or word
or christ
and the holy spirit is every existence
as the bond of love that exists between
them
and it is from this buliccio this inner
boiling
that the next stage then takes place
which he calls
ebolizio so if bulicio is the inner
boiling within god itself or god himself
ebolicio is when god boils over it's
like we lift the pan or the lid off the
pan
and god boils over into creation thus to
eckhart
the universe is created through the
outflow and
overboiling of god himself this also
means that creation itself contains
elements or traces
of this inner boiling and thus also of
the trinity
indeed eckhart sees creatures and things
in the world as
signs that point to god not just in the
sense that
their being is his being or that their
goodness is his
goodness this is also true but also in
the sense that everything in the world
in their created form
seems to also contain traces of of the
divine
inner activity of the divine trinity and
of the divine inner boiling
the sort of interactivity and principles
of the trinity to eckhart
is actually the very foundation of the
order of the world and of the universe
but just as everything flows from god
all things are simultaneously called to
return
back to him this is the central theme
for eckhart as a spiritual guide
it is here that he explores how the
individual human being can transcend the
limits of
created being and travel back on the
path to indistinct unity with god
which is after all the goal of all
existence
it is also here that the christology and
the figure of christ as the son and word
of god
shines through when it's his writings
the most and makes sure that there is no
confusion
about eckhart's identity as a christian
there are two main themes
that recur in eckhart's discussions
about the return to god
one is the birth of the word in the soul
and the second is the breaking through
into the divine ground
when we talk about the word in christian
theology this is referring to the logos
as mentioned in the first lines of the
gospel of john
in the beginning was the word and the
word was with god and the word was
god or more specifically it is referring
to the person of the son
and the trinity and thus also it is
referring to christ
the word or son is in a way identical to
god but in a mode of its own
the word can be thought of as god's own
knowledge or
thoughts about himself the word is the
principle from which everything in the
universe is created
and which is completely incarnated in
the living person
of jesus christ now for eckhart one of
the highest features of the mystical
experience or
rather mystical awareness is what he
calls the birth of the word or sun in
the soul
as we have said the birth of the sun and
god is always taking place outside time
and space in the eternal present
and secondly if you remember that
central idea of eckhart's that the
ground of the soul and the ground of god
is one
on the same ground this must necessarily
mean
that the word is being born in the
ground of the soul
at all times as well but we don't
realize this of course being caught up
with our lives and the world of
multiplicity
so what we want to do is return back to
god to that dark abyss in our soul
and realize that birth of the word but
how is this done
in eckhart sermons one of the things he
talks about the most and which is
most important in terms of practical
advice and
thus the the highest forms of spiritual
and religious practice
is what he calls detachment what he
means by this is not necessarily a
detachment from
outer things in the world like living in
celibacy and these things
although as a dominican friar he would
of course not be opposed to
those ideas but what he's instead
referring to is this kind of
inner detachment and and freeing of the
soul
from its limitations caught true
detachment
is nothing else than for the spirit to
stand as immoveable against whatever may
chance it of joy and sorrow
honor shame and disgrace as a mountain
of lead
stands before a little breath of wind
this is a cutting off of all attachments
to the world including the ego self and
its works
in a sense it is to annihilate ourselves
until there is nothing at all remaining
to eckhart detachment means to empty
ourselves of created things and return
to the silent desert of the soul which
is endless
and it is only in this absolute abyss or
ab grunt an
emptiness of the soul that god shows
himself
quote you must know that to be empty of
all created things
is to be full of god and to be full of
creative things
is to be empty of god by detaching we
increasingly become aware of god's
indistinction to all things and the
unity of our ground
we reach a knowledge that is really a
non-knowledge
in other words according to eckhart
through unknowing true knowledge or
rather awareness is achieved
the soul must be completely empty in
order to be
filled by god himself just like the eye
can only see color because it has no
color of its own
eckhart indeed considers god to be
nothing
not in the sense that he doesn't exist
of course but that he literally is
no thing and that its essence is a
complete and utter incomprehensible
abyss
or nothingness but as we have seen
it is this nothing that is at the same
time all
things our created nature by contrast is
absolutely nothing in itself at all
since all attribution of qualities
belong to god ultimately
so when we are detaching from everything
created we are really detaching from
nothing
from nothingness and returning to the
other emptiness that is absolute
fullness
more juicy paradoxes here of course
quote
eckhart's mystical way will be an
invitation to the soul
to give up the nothingness of his
created self
in order to become the divine nothing
that is also
all things and it is when we reach this
state of complete detachment and
emptiness of the soul that god can then
fill us and then it is then that we
experience
the birth of the word in our own soul
which is really taking place
in at all times in the internal now but
at this stage we we really experience
this as part of our being
and in a sense as such we also take part
in the sonship of christ
in so doing the self-knowledge and
self-expression of god becomes apparent
to us
in the words of bernard mcginn again
caught in perfect self-surrender
god's self-knowing becomes our
self-knowing
or better since there is no distinction
in the one ground
there is only a single essential
self-knowing
lastly another common metaphor that
eckhart uses to describe this
process of uniting with god is the
term or concept of breaking through into
the divine ground and this is where he
gets the most
radical with his language what he often
means here is that for us to reach
ultimate and complete union with god we
must go beyond
all images and all ideas and
in that sense we must also go beyond god
himself
the detached soul is never satisfied but
also always seeks to go
deeper into the abyss it passes by
god as understood as the creator of the
universe and with all these attributes
that we conceive of god as
having it goes beyond that god and
further into the divine emptiness the
divine nothingness
in eckhart's words quote i speak in all
truth
truth that is eternal and enduring that
this same
light the spark of the soul is not
content with the simple divine essence
and its repose
as it neither gives nor receives but it
wants to know the source of this essence
it wants to go into the simple ground
into the quiet desert
into which distinction never gazed not
the father
nor the son nor the holy spirit
or in another clear quote in the
breaking through when i come to be free
of will of myself and of god's will
and of all his works and of god himself
then i am above all created things and i
am neither god nor creature
but i am what i was and what i shall
remain now
and eternally he goes even further
quote as long as the soul has god
knows god and is aware of god she is far
from god the greatest honor the soul can
pay to god
is to leave god to himself and to be
free of him
in other words when complete
self-realization is reached and we have
returned to the limitless ground where
the soul and god is one without
distinction
god unbecomes or dies we leave
god behind and only exist in the silent
ground which is god's true essence
we have broken through into a total
unity with the divine
quote you should completely sink away
from your eunus and flow into his
his-ness and your you and his his shall
become
one hour so totally that with him you
eternally comprehend his unbecoming
is-ness and his unnamed nothingness
and this very conveniently brings us to
the ethical teachings of meister eckhart
this has all been very abstract so far
and you may think
what can he possibly extract in terms of
ethical and moral teachings from any of
this but in fact it actually
flows pretty naturally from these ideas
since the goal of a human being for a
card is to be completely detached from
created things this means that we are
also to be detached from our individual
will our own wills and indeed once we
reach
complete and indistinct union with god
there is nothing of us remaining none of
our will will still be there there will
only be god's will
we don't want anything anymore we don't
want to
act piously we don't want to do the
religious obligations anymore he calls
this active attitude to quote
live without a why in the same vein we
also
let go of all virtues this was of course
scandalous for a lot of people but very
interestingly this is also where we find
probably the biggest sign that eckhart
may have been influenced by the begin
marguerite paret and her book mirror of
simple souls
where she expresses basically identical
ideas
once we break through into the ground of
god's being
we let go of all virtues and religious
obligations
but it's very important to not
misunderstand eckhart here as
many have done eckhart and marguerite
pratt both
expressed these ideas and these
expressions are
primarily actually what got margaret
peret executed because people
didn't really understand what she was
actually talking about here
what eckhart's and paret is saying is
not that the person in question is
relieved
of performing his religious duties or of
being virtuous
instead what he is referring to is that
when the soul
is completely won or united with god
and is annihilated the will of the
individual person is
completely annihilated as well so he
will
still perform he will still be virtuous
he will still do his religious
obligations but that will not be done
through his own will
it will only be god's will who acts just
like god doesn't choose to be
good he just is good spontaneously
because
well he's god so too the person who has
been
united to god doesn't choose to act
virtuously he just
does so spontaneously because he is sort
of enacting
the will of god his individual will has
been annihilated and there is only god
left
in fact maester eckhart was actually
more of a supporter of an
active life in this world than many of
the other christian mystics of the
middle ages
a pure life of contemplation and an
active life
in charity and society was not a paradox
to him but were essentially connected
when we again reach union with god and
our actions stem spontaneously from his
divine will
our outer actions and active life become
a necessary and important extension
of that divine awareness it is here
in this world that we live out the will
of god
but indeed as mentioned earlier many of
these ideas of eckhart
did get him into trouble now make no
mistake eckhart was a successful
very well respected man for the majority
of his life but as we discussed
in the beginning of the video he was
indeed
tried for heresy by the end of his life
and after he had died
some of his writings selections from his
writings were
condemned as being either heretical or
very dangerous
and this would tarnish his reputation to
a degree of course but still eckhart
would go on
to be a very respected and influential
figure nonetheless
some of his immediate students like
henry souza and johannes tower
would become very prominent writers and
preachers themselves
and his influence can be felt generally
in the catholic church
there have been times in history when
his fame has diminished
of course but today especially in the
last century or so
he has very much been revived and is
often considered a great teacher
both in the church but also outside of
christianity
of course many of the new religious
movements of today often look at him
fondly and compare his ideas to those of
other traditions like buddhism
vedanta and sufism and of course not
without reason
his expressions of nothingness and
emptiness and even that the godhead
itself
is utter nothingness has often compared
to the buddhist ideas of shunyata
or emptiness for example i'm sure that
some of you watching can spot a lot of
these similarities that he shares with
people and thinkers of other religious
and spiritual traditions
i think eckhart is one of the most
fascinating figures of his kind in
really all of history there has been
some debate as to whether he
should be considered a mystic or a
philosopher or a theologian
and there are aspects of him that really
allow us to interpret him as all of
these three
i think the best thing for us to do is
to not label him with only one of these
categories
he was of course a successful scholastic
philosopher
highly influenced by the aristotelian
tradition
so in that sense he is a philosopher of
course but he also applied this to
theological ideas and he was a you know
in terms of his writings and sermons
they have a strong theological
speculative theological bans so
he is also a theologian but at the same
time there is no denying
that a lot of what he says is definitely
mystical and of course that's a very
difficult term but
in a general sense of course he is very
mystical in his ideas as well so
why should we limit him to only one of
these categories i think eckhart is
a thinker that really transcends these
kinds of labels
he expresses himself in ways that that
just
lends itself to so many different kinds
of understandings and
expressions but really who cares when
the result is so
intellectually stimulating baffling and
inspiring
all at the same time i'll see you next
[Music]
time
you